Note: Action -> Inspiration -> Motivation
---
It's finally over! Or is it? Yeah it's
definitely over. Oooor is it though? Yeah.
That's pretty much how I and probably
you as well felt about the conclusion to
the raid on Onigashima we have gotten
with chapter 1050 [Spoiler Warning].
So is this the end of the
battle? Of Wano altogether?
And what will happen next? While leaving a lot
of these questions open, we did get a couple of
really important answers in this
chapter as well. Here's a quick recap:
After Luffy's dramatic final attack
with an island sized fist, that
blasted Kaido into the ground, we get to see how
crazily powerful this punch of Luffy's gear 5th
truly was. It turns out that it carried such
incredible force, that it managed to drill Kaido
not only into the ground, but THROUGH the crust
of the earth into a magma cave that is revealed
to be located directly beneath Wano. Not
only that, but it turns out Big Mom has had
the very same fate after Law's and Kid's final
attacks. Which let's be real is pretty wild,
even for One PIece, but I guess it goes to
show how powerful Luffy and co have become
throughout Wano. Turns out the thing
the saw underneath onigashima wasn't
a hidden room full with poneglyphs and rare devil
fruits, but one full with molten flaming hot rock.
Kaido and Big Mom seem to be literally sinking
into this pool of Magma, I think it's magma,
because Lava would be when it actually comes into
the open. Anyways, the fact that Oda basically
has thrown these two Yonko into literal hell
is pretty extreme I think. Not at all what I
would have expected. The implication here seems
pretty clear also: These two people are gonna
be painfully dissolved in an instant, never
to be seen again. And to top this all off,
the two cracks the Yonko made in the crust,
cause an underwater eruption of the volcano,
that used to be Onigashima, as if to say: Yes
this is the end of the emperors Kaido and Big mom.
This message is driven home even harder, when the
narrator corrects his initial mistake of declaring
Kaido the victor. The actual winner is Luffy. On
top of that, Kaido also finally had closure in the
last chapter, realising that Luffy is indeed
JoyBoy, bringing closure to his big goal of
finding someone strong enough to defeat him. The
straw hats and the rest of the alliance celebrate,
chopper starts treating patients, including my
man Zoro, who seems to be in a truly dangerous
condition here. And Yamato gets the remaining
beast pirates to surrender, while Momo carries
a whole delegation of the scabbards and Hiyori to
the Flower capital, declaring Kaido's defeat and
announcing the new Shogun of Wano.
Oh, also a major shoutout to Franky,
who is the only straw hat that really looks like
he could still easily keep going after all this.
And so really, this entire chapter is screaming
that this fight is over the Yonko are dead.
The big question of course is:
Is that actually true? Or is
Oda-sensei throwing us one of
infamous red herrings here?
Does it really make sense for Kaido and Big Mom,
two characters in dire need of some redemption
and closure, to die burning to death in a
volcano? Kaido, who wants nothing more than
see JoyBoy and die an honourable death? And
Big Mom, who has no idea yet, that she has
been terrorising her own people in her feeding
frenzies? I find that hard to believe. I think
it's also a bit suspicious that it wasn't Mount
Fuji the main volcano of the island didn't erupt,
but onigashima at an angle. And the narrator,
who hasn't been super reliable recently either,
hasn't declared either of them dead.
Also Kaido has a literal fire form.
What I'm getting at here, is that I strongly
believe that we will see both Kaido and Big Mom
emerge from this magma pit, possible through Mount
Fuji. Maybe strongly believe is a bit too much,
I really hope to see this. However, not because
I think Kaido will activate his super ultra
awakening and attack Luffy again. I really think
that the fight between the alliance and the Yonko
is over. Luffy has been recognised
by Kaido. And most importantly it
doesn't look like Luffy will be able to do
any fighting whatsoever for quite some time.
What I would much rather see, is a cathartic
ending for Kaido's arc. I've mentioned that
before in my character analysis on him, but I
really feel like the best ending for him would
be defending an incapacitated Luffy against some
external force, like the Marines or Blackbeard.
But no matter if Kaido comes back or
not, I personally think that this was
by far the most epic and awesome battle we have
witnessed in the story. We saw Luffy and Kaido
grow and change over many many chapters. Kaido
has literally been fighting non-stop for over
70 chapters. He has faced off against
the scabbards, against the supernova,
against Yamato and then against Luffy. He
has shown why he is the strongest creature,
giving us both a broad variety of
fantastic attacks and fighting skills,
but even more importantly a crazy character arc
throughout the fight, that taught us more and
more about his motives and character, making his
ultimate defeat against luffy's final punch feel
truly cathartic. It forced Luffy to surpass his
limits and himself over and over again to actually
earn the title of Emperor, that he got before the
arc, as did every single straw hat along the way.
I know that battles and characters are a
very subjective matter, but to me personally
Kaido is my favorite villain in the story at the
moment. I just hope he sticks around a bit longer.
This has by far been the longest arc
and battle in the history of one piece
and especially when reading it back to
back without all the weekly discussions
and expectations built up, I find
it to be One Piece at its best.
This is driven home by Tama and Tenguyama,
who are heavily featured in this chapter as well.
We are being reminded of Yasu and his sacrifice,
all the events to even the way for
the raid to happen in the first place
and all the people who were putting their
hopes and dreams into Luffy to free Wano.
This chapter also set up a lot of things for the
future. Let me start with Zoro and Luffy. Both of
them are completely out after pushing themselves
to the absolute limit. And while I think that
Luffy will have to be awake for the final big
banquet, that surely will have to happen at the
end of the wano arc, I'm not so sure if Zoro will
be waking up any time soon. As I've speculated in
my Elbaf preview video, I think there is a really
good chance, that the two strongest straw hats
might be out for the first part of the next
arc, giving room for the rest of the crew
to shine and grow more. I'm actually super
curious to find out how taxing gear 5 will
be for Luffy and how hard or easy it will be
for him to go into that form again. I suspect
it might not be that Luffy can now just use
this form whenever, but has to master it first.
I also can't wait for an update to the Straw hat
bounties soon. That news bird with the new posters
is always a major highlight of every single arc
for me. In fact, I do have a bounty myself. 58M
Berries for the 580.000 awesome people of you that
are subscribed. I'm very far from reaching Luffy's
level or any of the straw hats really, but I am
determined to at least come for Treble's head,
who has 99M. So please help
me with that, by subscribing.
Yamato is another big factor
in this chapter for me. In case
you've been around that long, you know
that I wanted Yamato to become a straw hat
ever since their introduction. I would
be seriously hurt if it didn't happen
after all the hints we have gotten for it. And in
this chapter, the beast pirates even acknowledge
her as part of the alliance. Yamato is the one
who catches Luffy and who continued his fight
with Kaido until he got back on his feet.
I think we will get an answer to that soon.
There is of course the cliffhanger with Denjiro,
who proclaims the next Shogun of Wano. Will it
be Momo or will it be Hiyori? If it is Hiyori,
then Momo will keep sailing with the straw hats
100%. And given that he has Kaido's powers
and is now at least physically grown up,
I would have no issue with that at all. And
hell I'll even give him that he has grown
up personality wise as well. He has become a
true leader, made hard decisions for himself,
showed real courage and saved his people. If
HE became the new Shogun, that would of course
also be ironic, because Wano would get another
Dragon ruler, but this time a good one.
Other than that, it's crazy that despite all
the celebration and seeming end to the fight,
I still find it very hard to believe somehow that
wano will be wrapping up any time soon. There is
still so many lose ends, the government waiting
outside the border, questions to be answered...I
don't know. I'd like to think that there
is at least an Act IV waiting for us here.
If you want to get a full thoughts and
analysis on Luffy's battle with Kaido,
you really shouldn't skip this video right here.